pourquoi pas
[Musique]
mercure et je vous somme que ccc mine
chafouine et ce regard en dessous et me
dire ce que vous savez au sujet de mon
fils il car monsieur le pardon la
conduite du jeu d obscurité des
bizarreries ou fait curé monsieur le
ballon il n'y aura pas que des bruits
sinistre se répand dans toute la
province
on assure que de lectoure à montauban
les huguenots s'apprête à lancer une
offensive d'une large envergure vaulx-en
vélin oui pourquoi
mais au fait quel rapport tout ça avec
mon fils
sa réputation est au dessus de tout oui
il est parfaitement franc et ouvert
et j'ose le dire mais dior catholique
aucune personne de la région certes
monsieur le baron certes mais les
hérétiques ou une adresse diabolique
pour attirer à eux les jeunes âmes
signaux rentrent ils font miroiter aux
yeux des jeunes gens assoiffés de orion
et de coups d'épée les effets d'une
existence héroïque aventureux croyez mon
fils y seraient laissés prendre
si cela était vrai curé je le sais très
de mes propres mains dans un cul de
basse fosse au monsieur bayrou tout de
suite de grands coups dans les grands
moyens
la charité chrétienne nous enseignent
que si le mâle s'installe il faut
laisser aux pêcheurs moment la
possibilité de se sentir aussi vrai que
je me prénomme aurait la grippe a aidé
ses parents il ya tout un miracle si
monfils trop de près ou de loin autour
de l'espace une note
s'il conspirent ce que je ne suis arrivé
à trois avec la chiennerie éric kieken
jeu murray de la charité chrétienne
et je les laisserais - si entre deux
vieilles pierres de méga show mais
précisez votre accusation qui aurait
précisé vous en avez trop dit ou pas
assez
votre fils l'ont souvent au chapitre du
style je vous ai son planeur vous oser
affirmer une pareille monstruosité le
ballon des témoins m'ont rapporté les
faits mon fils mon propre fils violent
de la dame tient de bridging chez
castillane
c'est énorme mais vrai monsieur le
batteur d'estrade ce fourre tout ce sac
un trillion pas trop la charité
chrétienne aux lapins furets l'appel je
vous dis que ce castilla mois est une
ignominie une pire espèce
cette ignominie monsieur le curé cette
pire espèce mon père possède une espèce
de bijoux vaurien de sortu seigneur dieu
ou s'ils voient leur avenir acte de pure
clé de grâce de charme de clarté oui il
est vrai qu accordent à dire que cette
jeune personne et d'une grande piété et
on la respecte autant dans le pays que
son père et peut estimer qui s'agit-il
d'un trésor de keur dame mais de
générosité mon père oui près n'oublie
pas que je peux toujours comme lorsque
tu étais garnements te botter le train
de faire rougir le busage mais pourquoi
mon père et puisque je viens en vous
assurant de toute ma vénération et en
vous priant de me pardonner si je
commets une faute
sollicité de vous l'autorisation
d'épouser mademoiselle de castille
ronald r je me dis seigneur dieu mais si
tu viens montre ce que c'est que ce
monsieur de questi ac je vous ai entendu
tout à l'heure le traité ignominie 7
c'est un cas millions qui parut dans les
saisons de la politique par toutes les
couleurs de l'arc en ciel ni amis ni
ennemi tout ennemi tout à lui mais rien
n'égale les vertus de mademoiselle de
castille ac et catholiques le prague
pour à une nonne et hublot pour un
espion et tous les honnêtes gens
mon dieu mon père que je n'ai pas la
moindre intention d'épouser le père mais
seulement la fille
hélas actuellement les couleurs du
caméléon castilla qui s'harmonise
parfaitement enfin paraît-il avec celle
qu'arborent les chefs de la nouvelle
religion
n'insistez pas monsieur vous ne poserez
jamais la personne dont vous parlez je
vous conseille de vous rappeler que vous
êtes mon fils sans la tour miracle que
vous avez été tenus sur les fonds du
baptême par madame diane de poitiers qui
m'avez fait l'honneur de m'accorder sa
protection et que celle ci après la mort
de votre mère tué son amant je ne pense
pas manquer de respect à madame diane
lamarre au nom sans prétendre entrer
dans la famille d'un homme et estimé de
tous vos amis c'est son jeu vous pris
cette conversation au 20e jour
c'est une bourse pour votre voyage
une led j'avoue destiné pour votre
marraine c'est elle qui décidera de
votre avenir vous avez vu curé cette
allure s'était plaint de l'oeil cette
quitté de germination
c'est bien monfils sept enfants
néanmoins vous avez vu comment je vais
mater le petit gentilhomme aux îles
âgées plupart innocents ce que par ma
liste il a vu de quel bois je me chauffe
le lit
enfin grâce à dieu voici heureusement
terminé un petit événement qui aurait pu
mal tourner et cela grâce à votre
intervention purée merci je n'ai fait
que mon devoir n'est elle pas la nuit
d'hiver avance et oui oui
j'ai le collation je vais vous lire les
trois derniers chapitres du livre
huitième de la guerre du piémont je ne
doute pas que vous n'en soyez très
satisfait des trois derniers d'aller
voir c'est passionnant
[Musique]
et là c'est moi j'en ai bien monsieur
qu'est ce que vous faites dehors à cette
heure de la numéro un sud aux chevaux
disponibles ah oui monsieur mais ce but
je t'expliquerai nous partons j'ai pas
de 8 à perdre première c'est un enfant
mal élevé
le ciel de pointer le ciel est rapide
vous voulez dire qu réintégrer tirage
charité chrétienne soutane ne doit pas
intervenir que lorsqu'on a le temps pour
l'instant il s'agit de sauter curé de
sauter mais c'est vrai oui oui oui de
sauter sur de bons fruits de courir on
trouve subtile atom irak
là il boira mais les concepts de chevaux
nous allons clichés des deux écuries il
pour faire plus vite
nous allons emprunter le même chemin
avec lui alors je suis très mince et
monsieur à l'oral en pas de fausse
modestie vous êtes l'incarner un curé
alors je vais tenir de tuer
[Musique]
où va-t-on monsieur le baron a castilla
qu tonnerre de dieu vous demande pardon
de quoi est ce qu'on parle depuis ce
soir des guerres du piémont de l'ironie
curé nous on s'est moqué de moi je me
permettrai pas monsieur marc nouvelle
gare du piémont c'est les gars du
climont castilla tricasse tilhac et un
curé à cheval est un curé à cheval ouais
là allez en route soutane
[Musique]
monsieur qu'est l'histoire du curé de
mes draps au milieu de la nuit
à peine piloter en scène mais où
allons-nous comme ça vous dire bleu
vêtue que j'aille 6,9 à castillon à
monsieur il est bien tard pour faire sa
cour aux dames étaient bien qu'en ce
moment à cazilhac le gros chat road
c'est une habitude qu'il a maintenant 10
la nuit et je ne pense pas qu'il serait
très content de te reprendre sa jeune
chatte en train de ronronner avec un bel
oiseau tombé du ciel
crois tu vraiment comme mon père que ce
bon monsieur de castilla qui souhaitent
un affreux gredins afro grenat je ne
sais pas mais le très mauvaise
réputation j'en suis sûr depuis un mois
il passe pour être l'espion des
catholiques et trahir les protestants
dont il était pourtant l'ami et bien
quand je serai son gendre ce qui finira
bien par arriver en dépit de toutes les
oppositions genre est à 70 ans pour lui
inspirer de meilleurs sentiments
monsieur quelle singulière ine monsieur
de castilla qu'est née traître et
traîtres et mourra conseillant
l'archevêque lui-même y perdra son
éloquence mais bien tant pis pirou je
suis amoureux et quand un homme est
amoureux y est un état de folie
or monsieur pierrot oui messieurs
castilla qu elle accepte par de me
donner sa fille en mariage l'enlèveront
à sa barbe de croo charme de ce gros
chat les griffes et dangereuse monsieur
je ne risque rien n'a rien
mon père m'a toujours dit il serait
content tout savoir sur ce chemin avec
ses intentions monsieur veut faire ça
j'aime madeleine je vous suis mais je me
méfie bon dieu que je ne mets qui craint
le pire
j'ai mis pas dire je ne sens plus mes
jambes tellement j'ai peur
[Musique]
est ce qu'elle a dans ce mur nous
trouvons juste autour de la fenêtre de
madeleine c'est à dire en plein dans la
gueule du loup
si j'en crois les romans je ne serai pas
le premier cavalier amoureux qui aura
choisi ce genre de route
bon
allez-y mon maître il s'agit de ne pas
vendre les vertèbres
je suis moi
voilà fenêtre météo c'est sa chambre
c'est clair pour les veillées j'ai peur
qu'elle ne se fera qu elle ne s'irrite
je préfère peut-être qu'ici règle plutôt
que son papa faire c'est monsieur qui
mute et le hibou la chouette le champ
des cigognes ont battu grenoble chanter
les ventes italiennes
je supplie faites quelque chose parce
que si nous n'avançons du nord cuba ont
été tout bonnement tomber et ça ferait
un bruit intempestif par exemple de
chanter une chanson douce
il est attendu que dans les oreilles de
jeunes filles et aucune autre
[Musique]
j'aurais canet vous l'intention de faire
exactement a castilla qu cueillir des
fraises pur
j'ai un féroce appétit de fraises
monsieur le baron n'est pas gentil
on
[Musique]
shao renom du ciel que faites vous là
jean jean vous êtes fous mon père ne
dort jamais que d'un oeil
allez vous en vous ne vous doutez pas
les dangers que vous affrontez s'il ya
du danger à vous aimer madeleine
mais ces mois et demi ce danger allez
vous-en je vous en prie non pour tout un
empire
dites moi que vous m'aimez et que vous
me permettez d'aspirer à votre main vous
savez bien que je ne puis le dire votre
père ne voudra jamais de moi pour sa
fille je me fera changer d'avis si vous
avez de l'estiment pour moi ne pensez
plus à cette passion inutile
allez vous en ne soyez pas têtus
monsieur madeleine madeleine ne me
fermait pas votre coeur je ne pourrai
jamais ces travaux partez vous perdez
vous risquez votre vie est la mienne
vous serez à moi à madeleine car je vous
enlève messier de la tour me rate le
parfait ou moi-même j'appelle mon père
monsieur jean faire quelque chose qui
remuent approche ton purée
si comme ça j'arrête curé du jarret
[Musique]
puisque vous ne voulez pas m'aimer
puisque vous ne voulez pas me suivre
j'aurai le plaisir de me faire tuer sous
vos fenêtres et nous verrons si vous
endormirez mieux genre je vous aime je
vous aime mais cachez vous je vous en
conjure vous l'avez donc enfin vivre
mais mais cette fois monsieur je ne me
trompe pas mal à mettre le quatrième
avec toutes les chances à bath nous
sommes perdus puisque six clips from her
as trop tard nous sommes faits à aa
mais je ne me trompe pas c'est monsieur
de la tour miracle bébé qui se tient ici
perçu comme un héros sur mon mur
malheureusement je n'aime pas les
coureurs de nuit et quand je les trouve
mais moi je les a battus renom et
simplement comme de petits moineaux mon
jeu de gentilhomme vous devez pas voulu
ce soir dormir dans votre lit eh bien je
vais vous envoyer reposer dans un monde
et je suis certains avancent que
monsieur votre père me prouvera
drôlement créé les ce point être enfin
castilla que cette horrible bâtisse je
sais pas monsieur baroin c'est plus j'ai
des vapeurs et j'ai filé tout en face
des yeux calmement purée ça sent la
poudre on n'avait pas entendu ce sera
aussi la tour miracle en avant
château mira
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez les cuirs et peaux dont
monsieur parent curé albert je suis
assommé dieu mon père qui faites-vous la
ja perd connaissance cause de toi on a
tous eu ça devient fait tous les
protéger tous de la tour mirent à toutes
vos gars mieux que moi perles sur le
curé mais je suis blessé je me sens très
bien
non vraiment pas très bien aujourd'hui
l'extrême onction lui les derniers
viatique je n'en avais pas sur moi je me
sens bien même si fatiguée si l'on pût
saturé
retrouvez moi dans votre auguste bras
j'arrive vraiment je suis non plus
[Musique]
et moi à moi seulement un peu
contusionnée et ben on peut dire qu'ils
sont arrivés apic le pape à elle pour
être mon dieu quel carnage
enfin qu'on est mieux de ce côté ci du
mur que l'autre bon on va essayer de
remettre tout ce beau monde sur pied
monsieur mon maître a sonné il faut fils
édition plus vite et le plus loin
possible de sa taille et châteaux alors
voir bouthinon sentez vous êtes gentils
cas nations seulement motus à nos mots
que tu s'il vous plaît il ne s'est rien
passé ce qu'il s'est passé c'est rien du
tout je voulais remettre sur pied et moi
ces bonhommes ont moins de pouvoir et
après pour au soir monsieur de cadillac
du vent mademoiselle tant pis pour le
seul à bord
alors saignant qu'est ce que vous voyez
y avait mon transmis sur le canal des
gentilhommes oui ce sont plusieurs
messieurs sont plusieurs l'a couché dans
l'herbe voutré messieurs les uns sur les
autres ou bien curé oyonnax qui bouge
monsieur o
et puis tapez sur les autres qu'est
londres devient monsieur origer miss et
envers un oeil après l'autre ils se
redressent monsieur et puis retombe le
jaune gentilhomme il a un gros lâche
blanc sur l'épaule monsieur tout tachés
de sang au direct qui dort c'est bon
allez réveiller toute la maison prenez
avec vous rené guillaume barnabé tous
les autres domestiques qu'on décroche
les âmes des râteliers et qu'on a eues
me guérir tout ce beau monde avancer
vraiment repris connaissance
enfermez les dans les grandes caves où
il ya déjà les autres prisonniers
allaient vite je vous y rejoint le temps
qu'il la ramène sa capture je vais un
peu sermonné ma donzel
balade pas alors non pas
allez monsieur le baron et pour vous
réveiller allégée par an
la voilà au non monsieur le baron
bon ben voilà on a non monsieur jean
allons monsieur curé et bien
mademoiselle
pouvez vous m'expliquer les raisons de
ce spectacle avez vous encourager cet
effronté à venir ainsi soupiré chez moi
sous vos fenêtres on essayait de la tour
miracle en venant ici ne prétendez pas
vous offenser il m'aime et je crois
qu'il est sincère en affirmant qu'il a
le plus ardent désir de devenir mon
époux cent écus dr manière de venir
demander la main d'une table sans doute
n'avait-il pas d'autres moyens monsieur
vous savez que le messie roar elle
accueille pas à son père se fait l'écho
très complaisant des calomnies qui me
poursuivent et peut-être est-ce la
raison qui l'a fait venir cette nuit
plutôt que de vous adresser directement
la parole
je n'eusse pointe était fâché qu'il peut
y avoir une alliance entre les latour
miracle et ma famille
leur naissance leur position politique
et ma souplesse bien connu cela il pu
faire des étincelles qui aurait apporté
beaucoup de chaleur à notre foyer
comment pensez-vous ma vie je suis hélas
trop consciente de la dignité de la
position rosé seulement songé cette
ambition qui pourtant charme à mon coeur
que ceux d'hier
entendez vous par la dignité je suis
votre fille mon père quoique je ne
comprennent rien à la politique
si je ne pouvais pas votre conduite
entendre votre descendante et c'est
pourquoi je ne pourrais même si vous en
aviez le désirent suivre mon inclination
ce serait une trahison
c'est la première fois que je vous
entends dire de pareilles choses
mademoiselle et que supposé vous donc
dans votre père
ce dont vous vous vantez vous même votre
souplesse extrême vos actions blizzard
dont on parle partout j'ai des oreilles
monsieur hire qui va spire et puis
souffrir et cela par la grave dans
quelques minutes vous allez voir si je
suis trop palin jean delatour miracle
n'est pas mort mais il est mon
prisonniers dans quelques instants il
sera dans une de beckham à moins d'une
centaine de mètres de vous votre autre
oui mademoiselle avec les gens qui
l'accompagnaient prisonniers savez-vous
bien ce que cela veut dire
cela veut dire en son et cette rançon
c'est son père le cir aurait la grippe a
qui devra la payer
et pourquoi cette rançon ne serait-elle
pas son acceptation de votre mariage
avec ce jeune monsieur ainsi agirait
selon vos coeurs et vous voyez que je ne
suis pas un mauvais père
vous avez dit que vous alliez me faire
souffrir mon père c'est fait je souffre
mais vous acceptez je refuse
rendez vous je refuse je suis je vous le
répète trop consciente de mon la dignité
étant la fille d'un homme à qui tous les
gens estimables refuse de donner la main
monsieur de la toux miracle me fait la
cour depuis tantôt un mois à votre
absence monsieur tandis que vous pouvez
la campagne a comploté je ne sais quoi
il même ardemment mais chaque fois je
lui ai montré un visage de marbre et
j'en souffrais monsieur à cause de vous
ce soir j'ai eu la faiblesse de trahir
mon émotion parce que je croyais que
vous l'aviez tué c'était la première
fois ce sera la dernière
vous trouverez morte si vous essayez de
mener à terme aux affreux plan
cela dit adieu monsieur il va bientôt
faire jour je vais tenter de dormir je
saurai bien vous obligez attaquants vous
allez vous retirer immédiatement
qu'aucun canaille et me les séances ne
suis moi ce gentilhomme blessés qui
al'honneur d'être monfils très bien si
vous osez frappez moi j'ai la main
lourde
[Musique]
son dû monsieur de floralis par là sans
dieu mais ce monsieur de lasours miracle
que je vois ainsi guerroyant dès le
petit matin contre de la racaille en
liquette aux capitelles fleur de lys
quel bonheur de vous rencontrer et crée
le miracle ps ou encore vers ces petits
jeunes hommes avaient coûté tout pas les
problèmes mais c'est qu'il se voit bien
le petit latour miracle peste baron vous
êtes le diable en personne et votre fils
aussi en tournée est rien qu'une
certaine et un domestique pour vous
assister attendait puisque votre honneur
est sauf
je vais vous débarrasser de cette pègre
capitaine permettez moi de vous
embrasser pour le signal et services que
vous mieux de me rendre ainsi qu'à vos
filles soyez persuadé que c'était une
grande joie d'avoir pu être utiles un
ancien et un honorable amis depuis l'on
dira d'italie je ne vous ai jamais
oublié et je suis d'autant plus heureux
de vous avoir rencontré que je vais
avoir besoin de votre assistant non non
non tu rien fait par les capitaines
parler je suis tout à vous ainsi que mon
fils ici présent son serviteur et mon
curé pour le service du roi c'est la
même chose curé n'est ce pas capitaine
berthe baron certes mais suivez moi je
vais investir cazilhac
j'ai un compte à régler avec le seigneur
de ces lieux et je ne suis pas fâché que
vous en soyez témoin avec castille ac je
vous suis capitaine avec mon fils n'est
ce pas monsieur
bien sûr mon père venait encore on en
est à peine sorti rester chez moi
alors quoi crétin coire jean-foutre même
pas capable de me ramasser quatre
individus hors de combat
monsieur il est arrivé des soldats nous
étions les moins forts le capitaine
fleur de lys ordonne à monsieur de
castille ac d'ouvrir immédiatement les
portes de son château
sinon il se verra dans l'obligation de
les enfoncer
ouvrez vous êtes tous morts
pourquoi cette violence et se sont
désagréables et que pour l'honneur mais
l'espoir monsieur le dira ils sont
jeunes hommes je suis fier de cette
première visite silence félon très
hostile bien paraître devant moi après
m'avoir accusé depuis plus de quinze
jours par tant de faux rapports ses
tubes bien que dans ma vie j'ai
étrangler plus de trente cocasses qui
valait mieux que toi revenus et sont
bien sûr capitaine que vous faites c'est
voir sur ma personne parle ouvertement
j'ordonne monsieur de la tour miracle il
faut vous dire que les néo avance
partout que le roi la reine et tous les
seniors catholique du royaume pour
actuellement le plus grand danger
seigneur le monde où l'on veut nous
massacrer tous et voici monsieur le
cazilhac qui m'écrit tous les jours
depuis plus d'un mois qu'il surveille
les gens de la religion et qu'il est sûr
de leur innocence
or j'apprends que montauban est soulevée
et que lectoure est sur le point d'être
livré par son gouverneur font travaux
messieurs les fesses coincées entre deux
chaises alors messieurs je vous écoute
pas croyez-moi capitaine je suis
parfaitement innocent j'ai été trompé si
gens de religions son rotor et ils ont
sans doute découvert que jeter de vos
amis mais j'ai réussi à déjouer leur
méfiance et je suis en mesure à présent
de vous fournir plus d'un détail
intéressant fait on est frères rapport
bavard il ne tiendra qu'elle lui que je
ne te pend nous ne te pendre pas car je
parais groupe non tout ce que tu viens
de dire il n'y a pas un mot de vérité en
voyez d'autres vos gens avec un des
miens dans la cave du château et ils
vous ramèneront quelqu'un dans le
témoignage vous persuadera de la
véracité de mes dires
ainsi souhaite monsieur de fleurs de lys
je sens combien ma présence est ici
déplacés pourtant l'amour de la justice
me force d'intercéder en faveur d'un
malheureux rentra chez vous même vos
selles
quand monsieur de fleurs de lys agit
pour le service du roi personne ne doit
pas lui donner de conseils il serait
indigne capitaine que les catholiques ne
donne pas l'exemple de la clémence sa
orient de quelqu'un à pendre notre
seigneur nous a appris la mise elle
comme le meurtre n'est pas agréable à
dieu je sais ce que j'ai à faire
bravo capitaine rentrez chez vous
mademoiselle
on amène à dire étant pas qu'elle ne
nous amène pas vu toi tu me comprends
[Musique]
ton nom gaspard les secours de montauban
ta profession ministre du syntt
évangiles comment trouves-tu ici c'est
la femme castilla qui m'a persuadé de
venir me cacher ici je devais prêcher ce
matin pour un grand nombre de fidèles en
armes
eh bien tu prêches mais les gens en
armes sont des catholiques
excuse moi de te voir partie monsieur le
castille ac ou avez vous saisi cet homme
dans une réunion monsieur où je suis sûr
il ya en ce moment un bon nombre de
villes nous réunit pour marcher sur les
tours sans dieu il faut se dépêcher
castilla vous est une ordure mais pour
cette information et cette prise je
voulais sa vie s'ouvre combien
sommes-nous 12
messieurs de la tour miracle en bon
catholique
je vous invite à vous joindre à nous je
vous ai vu à l'oeuvre et nous avons
besoin de bras tel que les vôtres
monfils quoique blessés et moi sommes à
vos ordres capitaine nous irons jusqu'au
bout du monde pour combattre les ennemis
du roi et de la foi et de la fois je
vous accompagne aussi capitaine est avec
moi tous mes domestiques low ait lieu
quel cia qu'il vous faut bien cela pour
vous racheter plus nous serons pour
exterminer ces hérétiques mieux ce sera
ma foi
castilla que je ne vous aime points mais
si vous voulez combattre à nos côtés
j'accepte en ce qui concerne le mariage
l'horizon la prison là il serait en être
question nous partons capitaine un
instant messieurs une petite besogne
terminée qu'on instruisent le procès de
cet homme aurait dit quand mon ami je
suppose que tu ferais des façons pour
recevoir les conseils de ce vénérable
près pourtant capitaine je suis prêt
laissez-vous curé cependant tu peux
toujours te convertir jamais et je te
cite au tribunal d'en haut
si frais meilleure mine que toi alors
jeannot alo'o mitaine après procès
pendez moi ce trade
quant à nous messieurs en route je vous
rejoins et elle n'ouvre même pas sa
fenêtre pour voir à nos sinistres au
spectacle mené passer par mon maître
alors bon mais alors les actions d'éclat
nous attendent
sus aux hérétiques sus aux hérétiques
pierrot et peut-être revoir madeleine
bien sûr vous vous retrouverez le monde
est petit monsieur avant tout partons
d'ici déjà trop de pêcher sur la
conscience pour assister à celui qui va
se commettre ici
l'adieu gars par les secousses tu
croyais en ta cause
adieu jean delatour miracle la tienne de
phrases si vite oubliées la mienne
sus aux hérétiques pour m sus aux
hérétiques pia au jeune homme la
blessure je me sens à notre hub et va
trembler sur des coeurs monsieur à
je la porte de dinde mois est là
conserveraient jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours
madeleine dieu parce que je te retrouves
en attendant pierrot se sentir et hitch
qu'est ce qui vous a pris de partir
monsieur je me sentais si bien de chez
moi
au diable et amoureux monsieur au diable
au diable rhodia
[Musique]
l'avant peu trop perdu de temps monsieur
notamment à ses vagues notées je pense à
cet homme qu'on va prendre et moi je
prends sa madeleine l'attendre d'oust
plus les droites madeleine il n'a pas eu
un mot connaissance de la liste
paris n'a pas eu un regard pour son
amoureux à quitter les lieux où il avait
risqué pour elle pour tendre sa peau
heureusement que notre brave ami resté
pour dire la prière des morts si
hérétiques que soit le condamner je ne
doute pas que la vraie prière à dieu ne
le soit d'un grand secours pour son
salut heureusement que la bonne soutane
des familles a eu ce prétexte pour ne
pas nous suivre d'abord parce que ces
pauvres gens ne sont plus dignes d
héroïsme sent donc nous allons accomplir
mais surtout parce qu'il est bon qu'il
reste au poids de mademoiselle de
castilla qu afin de la décourager
d'avoir le moindre espoir à votre sujet
d'autre part les enfants machin enfant
dieu pardonnera les violences de ce
qu'ils combattront sa cause au monsieur
le curé saison où est la vérité
mon père georges genre mon père je ne
sais plus je ne sais plus rien jean
delatour me rater plus grands fous qui
existent mais rassurez vous une petite
fille il vous demande pas plus il est
parti les voyages et les aventures le
distraire on devient les choses
dieu seul décidera m
n'avez-vous pas quitter votre obèses
coûtent j'arrête votre cheval sans même
un vrai regret la guerre pierrot la
guerre tutelle civile ou religieuse
la guerre à cette voie on est la tour
miracles ont dépassé pour à la tour du
rac le coeur n'a pas de raison qu'on
m'avait dit hier mais le sens de vos
paroles ne t'ai pas le même jeu fait
taire mon coeur siro car le devoir
m'appelle mais j'aime mademoiselle de
castille ac
ce qui n'est possible des mots enfin
contentez-vous de prier pour votre terre
ces actions sont suspectes
il a le plus grand besoin de vos prières
vous êtes né pour cela pour obtenir son
salut je ne penserai qu'à mon père est
là pourquoi il a ce jeudi et la maman
des fourches et pardonnez moi je me
retiens pour ne songer qu'à nous
moi j'aimais mon logis la cheminée les
carreaux de ma cuisine s'attendaient
justement une jeune voisine de mes amis
pour lui confier mon affection
lorsque vous êtes venus enlever à la
poursuite de vos amours hamon m faut-il
que je vous soit fidèle madeleine née
tel point à l'image de la divinité
ce regard sévère pour toi d'une jours ce
regard unique que tu as créé pour elle
ya le vieux monsieur celui désiré
découle notre jeu ne se procurant refuge
pour la paix avec les questions stupides
martin sera la seule la seule que
connaîtra mon courage et rien à faire
ici
le baron et son fils calloch pour une
noble cause
le pendu pas la jeune demoiselle me
semble revenu à de meilleurs sentiments
j'avais la rentrée chez moi à pied
oui le christ me seul agréé de cet
effort oui à pied parce que henriette
c'était le nom de ma promise monsieur
oriente été la seule à savoir faire
relire mes casseroles embaumé m'aidera
allumé mon feu semble acheminer une fume
hélas hélas je ne l'enverrai plus hélas
là je me dirai plus madeleine et
m'apporte son oreillette ne sommes
encore à une période monsieur où il est
possible que vous entendre dire ça tu
veux te dire par là rien rien rien je
m'entends monsieur je m'entends
monsieur regardez là bas la troupe de
monsieur de fleurs de lys
encore un petit effort et nous les
aurons rattraper votre blessure
mais la cicatrice restera ainsi en
sera-t-il de mon autre blessure était là
bas tant mieux comme ça vous n'aurez pas
à attendre vous ennuyer picon monsieur
picon nous allons les rattraper
[Musique]
là tu fais du curé garnements il paie
pas l'amendé condamné mon père n'en
attendait pas moins de lui il me soulage
de mes scrupules pas de scrupules pour
l'hérétique baron la chair humaine est
la même pour tous capitaine trêve de
philosophie baron voilà un peloton si je
ne m'abuse qui porte les hideuses
couleurs de ces chiens de huguenots aux
armes aux armements 6 contre et vous le
dites fils votre père le pilote de
madame diallo premier combat mon père il
sera d'une grande réputation
monsieur même s'il vous plaît d'arbres
je me permets de vous attendre il vaut
mieux vous soyez seul à conquérir la
noire eh bien monsieur de cazilhac vous
êtes vert vous avez l'oeil qui
s'affolent se sont bien portants vos
ennemis qui courent vers vous n'avez
vous pas comme nous le désir de les
massacrer
je ne me sens pas bien monsieur mon x
mas rate mon intestin ont été secoué par
cette galopade et puis ne viendrait pas
vu que je frise la cinquantaine
messieurs les huguenots j'ai la chance
d'avoir en mai rend incertain castilla
qu est il des veaux il est chez moi
aussi messieurs de toutes les couleurs
paraît-il ce monsieur que capitaine vous
perdez la raison ils vous me perdais
voulez vous messieurs faire votre
peinture de ce traître je vous livre est
ce que tu as fia castilla voyez monsieur
on vous attend pour pitié capitaine
pitié pour les corses qu'on lui arrache
les prunelles retourne les ongles des
orteils
je n'aime monsieur que les combats
loyaux il me faut me débarrasser du
venin que vous représentez en iran
d'étaler vers ces messieurs ou moi même
je pique votre monture afin qu'elles
vous y conduisent elles mêmes
capitaine de fleurs de lys
je me présente par ophélie nac
nous sommes prêts à recevoir notre asso
merci pour la crapule que vous nous avez
transmises
nous saurons faire bon usage rien var on
devine à rien et regarde car nous vous
attaquerons monsieur nous pourrons ce
bon monsieur a tenu bon mais non
monsieur
bien mais où va-t-il
mais si rohr est la grippe a c'est un
brave petit bonhomme que votre petit
bonhomme mais où va-t-il enfin pour
suivre cette grande gigue sur son
canasson il a déjà ainsi et mis hors de
combat le baron de vélines ac et le
voilà qui court encore
il avait accompli des faits d'armes
digne de louange canon nous courtine
ainsi capitaine au courtil un laissons
le courrier en baron il est ivre de
bataille il faut que jeunesse se passe
il nous retrouvons à bientôt et puis il
me laisse tout seul en plus mon arme
en attendant puisque nous avons six
voyages ont décousu cette troupe
d'amateurs
n'est ce pas bar on devine ac les
amateurs vos hérétiques et je ne sais
pas monsieur
laissez moi me mettre au point avec un
homme est bien moore et monsieur ça vous
apprendra être du bon côté
ah ah ah que disait ce bon à votre champ
tôt et si je ne m'abuse non loin d'ici
auriez-vous labonté demi accueillir afin
de se mirer store ce combat ma soif est
avec plaisir que reason avec plaisir
j'aimerais savoir cependant ou monfils
en lécher votre fils où il est il a 20
ans quand bleus il faut que jeunesse se
passe
le filleul de madame de poitiers grand
bien lui fasse c'est une dame de bonne
renommée
qu'est ce que le devenir moi tout cela
tout seul pour fêter notre victoire sur
les hérétiques capitaine je vous invite
confiant monsieur je vous remercie
infiniment de la bonne volonté avec
laquelle vous m'avez suivi
vous êtes mon prisonniers la
plaisanterie détestable monsieur regarde
un peu jeune monsieur de l'atome irak a
plus jeunes c'est souple
ap st mais le premier reste inflexible
peut-être est-ce parce qu'il est au bout
de s'égratigner mais égratignant ne me
regarde pas monsieur alors soigné aux
parades mon petit coq
mais vous voyez plus résistants 6 heures
est inutile vous êtes entrevue main vous
n'avez plus qu'à vous rendre les pièges
l'honneur d'être le prisonnier capitaine
césar du bourg b monsieur et vous
n'aurez pas à vous plaindre de moi si
seulement vous me donnez votre parole de
ne pas chercher à fuir
je ne vous promets rien les vôtres
viennent d'être battus par monsieur de
fleurs de lys et je ne doute pas que
d'ici une heure ou deux je ne parvienne
à recouvrer la liberté
monsieur de la thur miracle je vous ai
reconnu à votre ressemblance avec votre
brave père je pourrais vous faire tirer
quelques balles dans la tête
je suis trop sentimental pour ça me
plaisait je vous épargne seulement je
vous en supplie tenez-vous quoi certes
vos catholique nous ont décimé
mais aux environs de lectoure et lecture
n'est pas la france
moi je pars pour orléans rejoint de
monsieur l'amiral et monsieur le prince
de condé
écoutez moi je vous en supplie n'essayez
pas nous échapper
il serait dur à votre âge de savoir qui
des huguenots ou des catholiques peut
avoir raison
je mens furet dès que j'en aurai
l'occasion capitaine de bombay à votre
guise
sans animaux alors pardonnez moi mes
précautions c'est vaste
pas trop ma confortable si vous n'étiez
pas si obstiné je vous ferai retirer
votre grande eau et des limons mais vous
devez comprendre mon bon ami
qu'important monsieur l'amiral la
nouvelle une défaite je le serai trop me
faire pardonner en lui apportant le
prisonnier l'importance que vous avez eu
la montée de me laisser faire
je suis très bien les yeux bandés et je
n'ai que faire de mes mains libres tant
que je ne suis pas hors de votre portée
capital à votre agenda marchons marchons
humain
mais
oui
[Musique]
oh
à
ça va bien mon petit héros un ça va 4 me
coucher pas mon champion alors ça va
toujours leur entame on peut mieux
capitaine
à surya une marche
nous passons la nuit ici monsieur oui
j'avais un serviteur un homme et pierrot
le comté vous parmi vos pauses aigner
ingénieurs monsieur vous êtes ma seule
capture
allez ce soir je vous des tâches allant
souper sur capitaine ce n'est pas de
refus je n'en peux plus et même je vous
promets ci-dessous paix est bon un
cyclone oli de ne pas m'enfuir jusqu'à
demain matin
mais voilà qui parle et je vous en ai
votre bandeau si vous voulez bien me
suivre nous sommes attendus par les
propriétaires de cette maison géante
accepté de nous accueillir cette nuit
j'en avais un peu assez de dormir à la
belle étoile et venez
bonsoir sacs à poubelle
je me présente corisande de peyrecave
aussi mon réseau nier jean delatour
miracle je suis fâchée de devenir votre
haute malgré vous cependant si vous
voulez me faire l'honneur de prendre
place à ma table
le souper servi madame je n'ai point d'
excuses à vous faire pour ma patronne
ise chez vous sans invitation
cela n'est point par ma volonté je
mangerai dans votre soupe et sans
scrupules et ne vous remercierez point
de votre bienveillance voilà bien un
seul ans des jeunes gens pardonnez lui
madame je vous prie et ne soyez pas
étonnés monsieur votre frère et vous si
monsieur de la tour miracle et moi même
faisons peu d'honneur à la conversation
certes il est mon prisonniers mais c'est
moi qui néanmoins que le vaincu dans
l'échauffourée où j'ai eu le bonheur de
le rencontrer mais je suis heureux de
cette prise qui me fera pardonner
mammifères mais vainqueurs ou vaincus
nous avons enfin le rayon merci
aimez-vous ronsard monsieur et du bartas
je préfère du bellay parce qu'il sait
comme personne
louer des perfections qu'avant de
pouvoir madame je ne laisse jamais osé
rencontre et on a pied d'un audacieux
capitaine de boer ben oui vous bien dire
à votre prisonniers qu'il y à du danger
a tenté de m'acharner mais pourquoi ils
demandent pourquoi parce que je suis une
personne par dangereuse je brûle madame
d'affronter des dangers qu'ils ont pour
moi tous les masques des retraites il
n'y va pas de même en ce jeune seigneur
dit moi mais c'est de la tour mirabeau
est ce le vin la bonne chère ou l'éclat
de manoel de peyrecave kivu délit à ce
point le langage on éclate ses yeux la
forme de célèbre sourire un peu faux
pourquoi fo je n'aime pas les un discret
monsieur si mignon que vous soyez si je
ris de vous c'est à mon gré à ma
convenance et selon mes secrets sera peu
de retenu s'il vous plaît alors quoi
nous sommes entre français ici et si un
catholique et sa cour une protestante il
n'y a selon moi que le diable qu'ils
puissent y redire car vous êtes
protestante une note we huguenote je
suis veuve d'un hugh nos cela vous
déplaît t-il bouleverse
parlez moi monsieur un paysan exactement
davantage en pas de paysans pour
distraire nos un gars je vous demande
pardon monsieur je dois recevoir ce
paysan à monsieur monsieur c'est eric
des catholiques ont pris ce matin notre
bon ministre m caspar l'esc où il s'est
réfugié au château du très loquace pia
ils ont pendu monsieur il était
commandée par le capitaine de fleurs de
lys et les deux messieurs de la tour
miracle
le jeune et le vieux le jeune maton
miracle c'est moi qui leur ai fermé ou
savais que tout montre hamas m m gaspard
lescout ministres de leur culte était
notre frère tué chinois tu as payé ça
sur le champ je suis désarmée monsieur
comme appart
mon frère est l'armée mon frère un peu
de mansuétude et sait se défendre le
coupable n'est ce pas monsieur que vous
n'y êtes pour rien
j'ai laissé faire la justice d amour car
ces hommes étaient de ma religion tu
m'apportes que le corps de m gaspard les
secousses se soient balancés sous le
ciel de nadia tu vas me pourrir et 5000
l'instant ces dames et aux prisonniers
et pas qu'il laissera personne ne
touchera un cheveu de sa tête monsieur
ne disputerait pas une juste vengeance
l'individu qui a vu le fond de souper
chez moi et l'assassin de mon frère ce
serait une injustice que de nous
l'envient sommes de nous remettre votre
prisonniers je ne livrerai point un
homme que je prends de présenter tout
chaud pour ma défense à monsieur
l'amiral
je suis désolé croyez le
qui veut soyez pas rendre de m gaspard
est
je le pleurerai toute ma vie monsieur je
ne mérite pas entraygues
je vous disais vous seul je suis
innocent mais elles vont poursuivre à
monsieur où que vous soyez à la coucher
l'église j'espère vous retrouver
je l'espère aussi madame soldat soldat
on emmène le poignet on est face à li
sur la paille et que nul de cette maison
de puisse arriver jusqu'à lui capitaine
vous avez tort vous le reconnaîtrez très
vite peut-être mais j'ai agi selon ma
conscience et moi même messieurs de la
tour miracle n'oubliez pas votre parole
et ne cherchait pas à fuir au matin
alors voir
[Musique]
chez bourdais est bien magnanime au fond
reset corisande dire que si je n'avais
pas cherché à enlever madeleine je ne la
connaîtraient pas
[Musique]
s'il n'avait pas juré de rester fidèle à
madeleine jusqu'à ma mort
à sète corisande
on part dans madeleine je t'aime je
t'aime
puis si tu tombes dans le sens me
conseillerez de quelques conseillers
besoin je ne souhaite que madeleine
oui cette corisande qu'elle est belle
mon dieu
elle vient à mon secours pierrot conseil
mois corisande corisande
m
[Musique]